CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi everyone.
My name is Claudio.
This is Alain.
We're two engineers in the
Google Drive Developer
Relations Team.
Welcome to this talk.
How's it going so far?
Well?
Good.
We're going to talk about
Drive and Android today.
And, well, if you've been here
yesterday, you saw a lot of
things in the keynote
about Android.
If you've been here today,
you've saw a lot of things
about Drive today.
We're trying to put everything
together now.
So let me start with
a simple question.
Can you please raise your hand
if you use Google Drive?
Wow, a lot of you use
Google Drive.
Can you please keep
your hands up?
Thank you.
And then, please, raise
the other hand if
you also use Android.
Wow, that's basically
all of you.
OK, please keep your hands
up during the whole talk.
Thank you.
So you probably know
all of this.
Google Drive is the evolution
of Google Docs.
We have this product where users
can store their files
and those files are accessible
everywhere.
You can store any
kind of files.
They will be safe
in the Cloud.
We will take care of making
backups and doing copies of
your files.
They will be always safe.
So it doesn't matter if you have
files on your phone and
you lose your phone.
Or you're on your laptop and
you lose your laptop, it
breaks, hard disk is broken.
It doesn't matter.
The files will be there and they
will be safe at any time.
But Google Drive is
not just storage.
It's not simply storage.
You've seen this today.
There are many applications
in Google Drive.
And we want you to use Google
Drive to collaborate.
So you store your files there.
You can open those files with
many applications, including
ours, but not only ours.
And you can collaborate.
You can share these files
with other users.
You probably know all of
this, so I'm going
really quickly on this.
But I'm going to show you
a single Google Drive.
And you've seen a lot today
at the keynote.
So Google Drive, as you've seen
today, is in your browser.
It's also offline now, but
that's a new thing.
Google Drive is in
your browser.
your desktop.
And Google Drive is on
your mobile device.
This is a screenshot of Google
Drive on Android.
Today we released the iOS
version, but in this talk, we
will cover the Android version
of the application.
And we will see how you can use
the Google Drive SDK to
write applications
on Android that
integrate with Google Drive.
What is this Google Drive SDK?
Well, it's an SDK.
So it's a software
development kit.
It's a set of libraries, a set
of methods, a set of classes,
that allow developers to
integrate their own
applications with
Google Drive.
Why would you do that
as a developer?
Well, there are many advantages
in doing so.
The first one is that as soon
as you integrate your
application with Drive,
you already have a
big, big user base.
There are millions of users
and there are billions of
files on Google Drive.
So as soon as your application
lands in Google Drive, you
have a lot of users that can
see, that can try, that can
buy your application.
And that is just the first
advantage that you get by
using the Google Drive SDK.
You also get many other
features for free.
You get sharing.
You get user identity
management.
You get collaboration.
You get the integration with the
Google Drive UI, so that
users can open files
from there, can
create files from there.
You've seen some examples
today at the keynote.
So in this talk, Alain and I
will show you how to take an
existing application--
which is a very simple Android
application that you might
probably know--
which is a single notepad
application.
And that's exactly the first
application that many of you
have built if you've ever
developed an Android
application.
This notepad saves and reads
file from the local database.
So stores files on the
local file system.
That's actually using
a SQLite database.
And we're going to
replace that or
integrate that with Drive.
So that the notes will be stored
to Drive, read from
Drive, and synced with all
the devices you have.
Does it makes sense so far?
I hope so.
So we're going to go
through five steps.
The first one is about how to
perform authorization on Drive
and on Android.
Because there's a specific
story, and we have some news
today about how to perform
authorization on an Android
app that uses Drive.
Once that is done, we will work
on making the application
asynchronous writing a
Drive Sync Adapter.
If this is not clear now, don't
worry, we're going to go
through all of these
steps one by one.
Actually, Alain is going to go
through the first three steps,
and then I'll be back here and
talk about integrating with
the Drive app for Android,
which you
probably know and tried.
And finally, we will also give
you some more tips on how to
optimize your application
for efficiency.
Remember this is a
mobile scenario.
So you have to keep in mind
different things then when you
write an application
for your desktop.
So let's start with performing
authorization.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: All right.
Thank you, Claudio.
So first of all, why do we need
to perform authorization?
So as Claudio said,
we have great user
base on Google Drive.
Millions of users, billions
of files, but the
files belong to somebody.
So that's why we need to get a
user account to get started on
Google Drive.
So we're going to do that on
Android by using the new
Google Play Services API that
have been announced today.
They're not yet available,
but they're coming soon.
And we need to first start by
getting a user account.
So I don't know about you, but
on my Android devices I have
multiple users.
I have my corporate account,
since I'm a Googler, and I
also have my multiple
Gmail accounts.
Well, when you run an
application that requires
account information it's best if
applications can prompt you
to choose the user to use
with your applications.
So we do that by using the new
Account Picker API, which has
a simple static method called
New Choose Account Intent.
This returns intent that you
can start from any activity
you exported to show account
user dialogue that the user
can pick from.
So for our application,
we need to run
from a Google account.
So we create a new intent.
We might specify [INAUDIBLE]
account if we saw that in our
preference.
And then we specify the account
intent that we want to
come to Google accounts.
Then we simply started a new
activity in Android as you
know how to do it.
And we specify the request code
the activity has been
started with.
Once the user has chosen an
account, so performing an
action on it, the [INAUDIBLE]
method would be code
backed by Android.
We have a request code, so we
need to make sure the request
code is the one we specified
when we started the intent.
The resort code is OK.
So the user actually
chose an account.
And then we have data.
Once everything's OK, we get
the account name using the
data and the aesthetic string
provided in the account
manager class.
So how does this look
like on Android?
There you go.
We simply used two lines of code
to start a new activity.
This is a built-in intent
provided by [INAUDIBLE]
services.
The user can choose the account
to use, and if the
account is not there can add
a new google.com account.
Now that we have an account,
we need to
authorize it to use Drive.
The user needs to authorize
applications to get their
Drive files and work
with them.
We're going to do that using,
again, one of the new Google
Play services API called
Google Auth Feature.
It has a static method called
Get Token, which returns an
access token if everything
works fine.
You specify your context on
which the method needs to run,
the account name for which you
want to get an access token,
and this code you want
to authorize.
So in our case, we want to
authorize our application for
[? OverDrive ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
Scope.
The Drive API has a bunch of
[INAUDIBLE], one of which is
[INAUDIBLE].
So you the user can choose
to grant access
to it's entire directory.
We don't really recommend that,
because that can be a
security issue.
Especially for Google, for
example, we won't grant access
to our entire directory.
And for any users, they might
have private files like their
tax information, et cetera, that
they don't want to grant
access to for a variety
of application.
So OverDrive API provided a
[INAUDIBLE] scope called
Drives [INAUDIBLE] which only
grant access to files that
have been created by this
application, or specifically
opened with this application
using the Drive web UI or-- as
Claudio will explain later--
using the Android application.
So we called Get Token hoping
to get access token.
If you the user never granted
access to your applications,
it will throw a user recorded
[INAUDIBLE] off exception.
This exception will contain an
intent, but your activity can
start to show the user
the [INAUDIBLE].
So we can allow or deny access
to the applications.
Get Token needs to be run
outside of a UI thread in a
sync task or in our simple
applications that we're
releasing in a Sync Adapter.
Now, when you start the intent,
this is how the new
green screen looks like.
Again, this is a preview.
It's not yet available.
It's coming soon in the SDK.
So here, we can see that
Notepad, our application, is
requesting access to the Drive
to files that have been
created by these applications
for the account
driveservertest@gmail.com.
So we didn't cover everything,
any corners, on authorization.
There's a session starting right
after ours, at 5:15,
from Nayiv called building
applications
that use web APIs.
This session would go through
how to register your Android
application on the API council
so that we know your
application is authorized
to use the Drive API.
Any corner cases, like how to
call get token in a sync task,
it sends us errors if a user
decided not to use an account
or denied access to
your application.
And also explains how to cache
expired tokens, because access
tokens only works for one hour
and needs to be refreshed when
they get expired.
So now that we have an account
to work with, we need to
unblock the UI thread.
We would go from this, so
this is a nice queue--
synchronous--
it's easy to understand.
When you read [INAUDIBLE]
codes it goes
like step by step.
But, wow, it blocks
the UI thread.
We don't want that, like as we
saw during the keynote, we're
putting lots of effort into
making every UI looks good and
not blocked.
We're [INAUDIBLE]
for every users that use
Android, and provide
applications, so we're going to
modify the existing Notepad
applications coming from a
synchronous application to
asynchronous applications
like that.
It's going to be fast.
Every task will race into a
server, and it will leave the
UI thread alone.
How are we going to do that?
Well, how many of you have ever
seen this screen before?
Yeah, it's annoying, right?
Well, we need to take
care of that.
So why do we see this screen?
It's because Android will kill
any application that has
broken the UI thread
for too long.
The Notepad application is
reading from the database in
the UI thread, so it's quite
fast, but the methods are
getting [INAUDIBLE]
and we need to modify that.
Also, since we're now
integrating with Drive, we
can't make the web UPI calls
on the UI thread.
Because starting from modern
Android, the system will
simply queue our applications.
So we have multiple ways to
unblock the UI thread.
One of which is using
a sync task.
Another one is using
a regular thread.
In our case, we're going to
use Sync Adapters because
we're syncing our local
database with Drive.
Now in this section, we
cover how to write
a Drive Sync Adapter.
A Sync Adapter is composed
of three main components.
A content provider, so this is
already available in the
Notepad application.
We already have a content
provider that helps your
application talk with
the database.
And provides helper methods to
insert new data, read data,
make queries, et cetera.
We also need a Sync Adapter
service about the application
we explore.
And tells Android that this
type of data can be synced
with a Sync Adapter
using a service.
And then the main component, the
abstract thread and Sync
Adapter, which is a main class
we need to implement, will
contain all the sync logic.
So we'll sync regularly the
local database with Drive, or
pull changes from Drive, and
sort them in the database.
We also added a settings page.
So that the user can also change
accounts, and choose
how frequently he wants the
syncs to be performed.
So let's take a look at
a Drive Sync Service.
This is a really simple class.
It looks the same for most sync
service you'll implement
if you don't have any specific
requirement.
You just need to override
two method and
create it an unbind.
So uncreate is called by Android
when a new service
needs to be instantiated.
And unbind is called by Android
when a new content
needs to be bound with
a Sync Adapter.
So the end create method, in
our case, we want a static
Sync Adapter.
So when Android instantiate a
new Drive Sync Adapter, we
simply instantiate a new
Drive sync service.
We instantiate a new Drive
Sync Adapter as a static
attribute, and we make sure it's
[INAUDIBLE] safe using
[INAUDIBLE].
Now, unbind again it's
quite easy when
it's called by Android.
We simply return the
Sync Adapters,
Get Sync out of Binder.
Which is in the original
implemented by the abstract
thread Sync Adapter class.
Now as an activity, or service
Android, you need to declare
it in the Android manifest.
So you do that by adding
a new service tag in
your Android manifest.
Add an intent feature saying
that [INAUDIBLE]
Sync Adapter pardon.
And then link to the Sync
Adapter resource [INAUDIBLE].
Picking up [INAUDIBLE]
integration here it is.
So particularly when you Sync
Adapter, you specify the type
of content the Sync Adapter
is able to sync.
We're using the same authority
as the simple Notepad
application which is
called through the
Google provider of Notepad.
The account type for which
data be synced.
In our case, google.com since
we are syncing with Drive.
And then whether or not the Sync
Adapter is user visible.
This is a nice setting.
If you set this to true, the
Sync Adapter will appear in
the account settings page in
Android, and the user decides
to turn on or off
your service.
And again, comes for free.
Now the Sync Adapter.
The main method to override is
on Perform Sync, which is
called when a sync needs
to be performed.
[INAUDIBLE]
implied.
Account, so this is the
account for which we
need to sync data.
There are some other parameters
and the content
provider, which will help your
class get data back and forth
from the database.
In the end, when you're done,
you should be sent the result
in the sync result parameter
if everything
goes well or not.
If there was an error, Android
will take care of trying again
to sync, et cetera, et cetera.
Why did we decided to
use a Sync Adapter?
Well, there are many things
that come for free.
If your device is offline
Android won't try to sync.
This is nice.
You don't have to handle that.
If there's a failure, Android
will try again.
If you update your database,
and tell Android that the
database has been updated,
Android will know that a sync
needs to be performed again.
And will try to perform a new
sync, et cetera, et cetera.
There are many things that come
for free with minimum
work from your part.
Now we implemented
all the classes.
Well, we didn't implement the
sync logic which will be
covered later.
But once all of this is done,
you need to enable the Sync
Adapter for your applications.
You do that by, for instance
this is done from
our Settings page.
We say that for the specific
account, we want the Sync
Adapter to be synced
automatically.
So all data will be synced
automatically by Android.
And then we'll also specify
a sync priority.
For instance, you want your
sync to be performed every
five minutes, 15 minutes,
et cetera.
And once this is done, well,
this is what the accounts page
looks like on [INAUDIBLE].
And as you can see, the Notepad
appeared and is
actually syncing now.
So we get an account.
We enable the [INAUDIBLE]
application to use accounts.
We authorize the applications
to talk to Drive.
We are still starting to
implementing a Sync Adapter.
Now let's talk to Drive.
So the Drive SDK provides
an API.
We recently released version
two of the API yesterday.
And the API is a [INAUDIBLE]
API.
So it let's the [INAUDIBLE]
least create, update, delete
resources on Drive which
[INAUDIBLE].
And other type of resources as
well, such as the ACL which is
sharing if you want to share
your document with other
users, et cetera.
This is not covered
in this talk.
We are only using [INAUDIBLE]
resource because we are only
syncing the database
with the Cloud.
So now that our application is
able to talk to Drive, we're
going to first retrieve all the
files that are available
in Drive and has been created
by applications.
Why do we need to do that?
Well, the user might have
installed your application in
multiple devices because your
application is awesome.
And you want all the files
created by one application to
be available on the other one.
So we're going to list the files
that have been created
by your app and sync that
with the local database.
Then if a user created a new
file on his device, well you
need to sync it to Drive.
So we're going to see how to
create a new file resource on
Drive and upload the
content to it.
Then we're going to sync
changes, local changes or
remote changes to a
local database.
This won't be covered in this
section, but Claudio will talk
about it in the end.
And also, hand deleted files
in case a user decided to
delete the file locally.
We need to make sure that
it's deleted on
Drive and vice versa.
Now how do we retrieve
files from Drive?
As I said, we're going to list
existing files available in
the user's Drive.
We do that by first
instantiating a new list
request on the file resource.
So this is a [INAUDIBLE]
API, but we provide a
client library that
makes it a lot easier.
As you can see, we instantiated
a new request.
This is a wrapper around
an HTTP request
with one line of code.
We set the query parameter,
because we only want to handle
text/plain file with
[INAUDIBLE] type.
We have the least end point
handles multiple query
parameters available,
and documented in
our reference guide.
Once we instantiated that, we
executed a request and get all
the files that are available
in the response.
We [INAUDIBLE] through
all the items.
Get some metadata such as
the file ID, the title.
We also get the content
using the [INAUDIBLE]
URL provided in the [INAUDIBLE]
metadata.
So the [INAUDIBLE] might be no,
in case if no content are
available in our
starting Drive.
So those are some [INAUDIBLE]
cases you need to handle.
And then we store all of that in
the local database using a
SQL [INAUDIBLE].
And we iterate through all the
pages as there may be multiple
pages returned by
the Drive API.
OK.
So now the user run the
applications, gets all the
files that has been created
already in his local instance
of his applications.
Now he created a new file,
and wants it to
be synced with Drive.
How do we do that?
We create a new file resource.
Set some metadata
such as a title.
Set the [INAUDIBLE] type.
In our case, it's a text/plain
[INAUDIBLE] type.
And then we also get the
content of a file.
Then call the Insert method,
which is also a
HTTP rest API request.
Which is [INAUDIBLE] through
our client library.
So with only one line of code,
you send both metadata and the
content of a file to the RPI
using, what we call, a
resumeable [INAUDIBLE]
protocol.
This comes for free for you.
Only one line of code.
Of course there might be API
errors that need to be
handled, and will be covered
when we release the simple
applications.
Once this is done, the API
returns the metadata, such as
a file ID, that we need to store
in our local database so
we can sync.
So we know which file
has to change, and
can sync in the future.
We also store all the metadata,
such as when the
file has been created, when it
has last been modified, et
cetera, et cetera.
Now, this screenshot doesn't
really show you, but it works.
But let's pretend it works.
You click and save, done,
sync to Drive.
Now Claudio will explain to you
why it's interesting for
you to [INAUDIBLE]
to your Drive app for Android.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
Thank you Alain.
So, you as users, as Android
users, probably have the Drive
application installed on your
device on your tablet.
And that is probably the
starting point whenever you
want to work with one
of your files.
So you have to take that in mind
when you write your own
application.
You have to consider that users
can start from your app.
And in that case, you have to
provide a way for them to
access their files.
But users can also start
from the Drive
application that we provide.
And so, every time they try
to open a file that your
application can open--
and they try to do that from
the Drive application--
you can make sure that
your app does that.
How do you do that?
The Drive application fires an
intent every time you try to
open a file from it.
An intent that has specific
parameters.
So you can register your
application in order to
receive specific intents that
represents files and
operations your application
can take care of.
So every time you tried to open
a file from the Drive
application, the intent will
have a specific action
that is a new one.
A new intent action that has
been just defined which is
called Drive Open.
So if you want to receive that
intent, you have to register--
well, export--
an activity in your application
that can receive
intents whose action
is Drive Open.
But that is not enough.
With Drive Open, when you
register for that, you're
saying I want to listen
to all kind of files.
You can restrict that to
some specific files.
And, for instance, you might
want to restrict that to some
specific [INAUDIBLE] types.
Our application, the Notepad
application, we're showing
only opens text files,
plain text files.
So we only want--
or HTML files which
are text files.
We only want this application
to listen to those intents
that are for text files
or HTML files.
So we can filter that,
and specify that
in the intent filters.
And this is what you should
export in your manifest.
As I said, you have to export
an activity that says I can
listen to the Drive
Open intent.
You specify the [INAUDIBLE]
type.
You specify your application ID
which is a number, an ID,
that you get from the
APIs console.
And whenever you listen to one
of those intents, you will
also get a complete path that
includes a resource ID.
The resource ID, or file ID,
is the unique identifier of
the file the user is
trying to open.
So you get this intent.
Check if the intent is what
you can listen to.
And if it is, you have a unique
identifier of the file
and they're trying to open it.
And this is how you do
it in your code.
So you have to export an
activity that implements this
single method on Create.
When this is called, this is
called whenever you listen to
one of the intents you're
registered for.
And so the first thing you
have to do is to get the
intent you're listening to.
From the intent you can
get the action.
Remember, we only want to listen
to those actions that
are Drive Open.
So we just check
it in our code.
If the action is Drive Open,
we do something which is
specific for our app.
If the action is not Drive Open,
we'll probably want to
ignore this intent.
It's not what we're listening to
in this specific scenario.
So when the action is
Drive Open, we check
the resource ID parameter.
And that is the unique
ID of the file.
And then we can use the same
code that Alain showed before
to open a file from Drive.
So the API provides us with a
method like surveys.files.get.
We check [INAUDIBLE]
a unique ID like this and
returns you the file
as you've seen it.
But there is a caveat here.
When the intent is fired, we
know what file the user is
trying to open.
But we don't know who the user
is, because that information
is not part of the intent.
So whenever we get here in this
part of the code, and we
know that a user is trying to
open a file, we still have to
go through the account
user dialogue first.
See who the user is.
So ask the user to pick one of
the accounts he has on his
device, or create a
new one, as usual.
And then try to open a file.
This is how it looks like.
We're going to show
all of this live.
We have this application
on our device.
We're going to do a live
demo at the end.
So in this case, I started from
the Drive application for
Android and tried to
open a text file.
This dialogue popped up and
said that I have three
applications that can
open this file.
And one of them, the last one in
the list, is Notepad which
is our application.
So if we click on that, then our
file will be opened into
our application.
You're going to see this
in a few minutes.
Lastly, I'm going to give
you some more tips.
So I have actually two more tips
for how to optimize your
application for efficiency.
Remember that we are in
the mobile scenario.
And in a mobile environment,
when we are not on wi-fi, when
we're 4G or 3G, downloading
files can be very expensive.
And can be very slow.
Files in Drive can be up
to 10 gigabytes big.
If you try to download one of
those files, with the best 4G
available, it is still going
to take more than 20 hours.
So this is something we don't
want to do very often with our
mobile device if you're
not on wi-fi.
So we have to remember this
when we design our
application.
And what we have to do is we
only have to download files
when it's necessary.
When it's absolutely
necessary.
So we have to find a way to save
bandwidth by using the
local database as a cache.
It's pretty obvious.
If we have the same file in the
local cache, we don't need
to get it back from Drive.
But we need to find a way to
understand if the file we have
in the local database
is the same as the
file that is on Drive.
One of the fields in the file
metadata we can get from Drive
is the MD5 checksum of
the file content.
So if we store that checksum the
first time, the last time,
we downloaded the file we can
use it to compare it with the
checksum that is coming from
Drive the next time we try to
download the same file.
So the algorithm here
is pretty easy.
We send request to get
the file metadata.
Then we compare the
MD5 checksum.
If they match we only need
to update the metadata.
If they don't match, there's
nothing else we can do.
The file is updated so
we have to download
it back from Drive.
And this is how we do
it in our code.
This is part of the sync logic
that Alain presented and that
he promised me to
show it to you.
So every time we need to sync
files we have to be smart.
And this is actually the
implementation of the
algorithm that I explained
a few seconds ago.
So we're trying to push a file
from our local file system.
So from the local database,
from the Android
device, into Drive.
So what we do is we have to
check, compare, the checksum
of the local note that we
have with the checksum
of the file on Drive.
If they're equal, we only send
an update for the metadata.
We are not sending
the content.
Remember, in our case, the
content is pretty small.
We only deal with text files.
So the content is
usually small.
But remember, your application
can sync videos with Drive.
And of course, big videos can
take a lot to be transferred.
And remember that bandwidth
is also
expensive on mobile devices.
So we want to be this.
We want to be here in
this [INAUDIBLE]
only when necessary.
Here we have nothing
we can do.
We update both content
and metadata.
The library does this for us.
We have two simple methods
we can use.
They look very similar.
So we have this update method,
and we're done.
That's all we have to do.
But we need to try to be
in the first case all
the times we want.
And here is the second tip that
I want to share with you.
Our application syncs
when it starts.
It syncs all the files from
Drive and covers them into the
local database.
Let's say, in the future,
you want to sync again
with all the files.
Well, if you have nothing else
than that, nothing else than
those methods, all you
can do is download
all the files again.
Compare each file, one by one,
with those you have in your
local file system.
See if they're the same.
See if there are differences And
replace the old one with
the new one.
Same thing with deleted files.
You have no way to know if
a file has been deleted.
Then just checking the
list of files and see
if the file is there.
Of course this is a resource
intensive process.
It's very expensive.
You have to download all the
files every time you want to
sync your local [INAUDIBLE].
But we like it.
There's a feed, called
a changes feed,
in the Drive API.
Which returns the changes to
all the documents since a
given time.
So this feed will say, starting
from the last thing,
last time, you checked.
Starting from time x, this
file has been added.
This file has been deleted.
This file has been changed.
Everything else you
know is the same.
So you can save a lot of
bandwidth just by using this
changes feed instead of
downloading all the files.
You only download those files
you know that have changed.
This is also implemented by the
library, and the usage is
very similar to what we've
seen with the files feed.
Instead of doing
surveys.files.method, which
was list, or insert, or update,
or delete, or anything.
Here we have
service.changes.method which
is list in our case.
So we want to list all the
changes starting from a
specific change ID.
So all the changes
are numbered.
So if you last time synced at
change ID 200, next time you
only need to remember to sync
from change ID 201.
That's it.
You get a list of changes.
And for each of them, you just
need to check if the change
was a deletion.
And in that case, we sync the
local copy of the files or we
delete the local copy
of the file.
Or if it's not a deletion,
there is an update.
And so we get the file, and we
do the syncing, which is
updating the file or [INAUDIBLE]
the file.
Of course, we have to do
that for all files.
That's just a [INAUDIBLE]
loop.
I don't think there's nothing
to explain here.
With this I think we can
move on to the demo.
And we are going to show you the
application we built that
does everything we showed you.
Let me switch.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Is it on?
Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It is.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Am I on?
Yes.
So, thank you Claudio for
those performance tips.
This is a live demo.
I'm on wi-fi.
So I can be wrong in
the use of manners.
So as you can see, I don't have
much wi-fi connections.
[INAUDIBLE]
connected.
OK, let's try this.
So I open my Notepad
applications.
As you can see, this is the same
as you implement if you
go through the Android
tutorials.
List of files.
Nothing new here.
Then we added the preferences
page.
You go there.
As I mentioned, you can choose
the account you want to use in
your applications and also
set the sync frequency.
So now let's try to choose
another account.
As I explained at the beginning
of the session, this
is using one of the new Google
Play services API called
Account Picker.
With one line of code you
get an intent for free.
A user can choose to use
another account.
Let's try the third one.
OK.
This account has never used
this application before.
So my Sync Adapter tried to
get access to the account.
It failed.
Get the exception.
And now it's sending a
notification to my user to
grant access to the app.
I click on it.
It's on wi-fi so hopefully
it's going to work.
This is checking if the user
ever granted access to my
application before.
Now I get the approval screen.
I can carefully read the text.
Of course everybody
reads the text.
And then decide whether or not
to grant access to the
applications.
Well, in fact, I didn't want
to use this account.
So I'm just going to cancel and
go back here and choose
the account I used before.
Now, for the sake of our demo,
I'm going to put the sync
frequency every five seconds.
This isn't recommended of
course, but this is a demo.
Now let's open a file.
Which one?
Let's say the first
one, To Dos.
So we talked about how to get
an authorized account,
implement the Sync Adapter talk
to Drive, talk to Android
API to sync data, and also use
a changes feed to improve
performances.
Now what else do
we need to do?
Android.
Done.
Let's save.
So now this is saving to
the local database.
The Sync Adapter knows that
the local database has
changed, and will try to sync
again using the Sync Adapter.
Now let's use the Drive
applications.
Hopefully this already synced.
So trying to look for changes.
Let's wait.
I want to show you that it
actually synced, because
otherwise I can fake
everything.
As you can see, To Dos has
been updated at 4:41, one
minute ago.
Let's try to open it with one
of our applications, because
if I open it with mine,
well, I don't know.
I might be faking
the database.
So I want to be proving
you that I've been
using the Drive API.
So let's say, I'm using
the Document Viewer.
So bring the file.
This is getting data from
Drive and launching the
applications.
As you can see, we can now enjoy
syncing files to Drive.
This is working.
Thank you.
All right, wow, this
is awesome.
I can create new
files on Drive.
Get data from Drive, sync.
This is perfect for any
type of applications.
Gamer applications, for example,
like you want to have
saved data sync across
all your devices.
Get that for a few
lines of code.
Now you can't notice here, but
I have a note that is not
synced on my Notes list.
Why is that?
Well, this is a text file that
has been created by another
application, not by mine.
So my application is not
authorized to read it unless
the user specifically approved
this file for my applications.
Well, with the Drive
app on Android, you
can do that as well.
So I'm going to click
on Final Notes.
This is firing an intent on
Android, looking for all
applications that handle
the Drive Open Intent.
And my Notepad implemented
that, so let's open it to
Drive with Notepad, sorry.
Opening, what it did is it sent
a request to our back end
saying that Notepad applications
is now authorized
to read and save data to this
file using this application.
Now, as previously mentioned, I
don't know which user fired
the intent.
So I need to prompt the user to
choose what account to use.
We are working on improving the
story, but bear with us.
For now, this is the
best way to do it.
I'm choosing the second account
which is my test account.
And now I'm pulling
data from Drive.
Again, this is on wi-fi,
hopefully--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: This
is when they clap
their hands, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: For
real this time?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Oh, there
you go, it worked.
Isn't that awesome?
Then I go back.
Come back to Drive.
Go to my Notepad applications.
As I can see, Final Notes
is right there.
Now my application
is authorized
to read these Notes.
Two lines of code, you get
accounts authorization,
background syncing, and
you talk to Drive.
Now all your local files, all
of your local data, is now
synced to the Cloud for only--
I don't know--
a few lines of code.
A hundred?
Not even.
We won't be releasing the
[INAUDIBLE] right now because
the Google [INAUDIBLE] services
will be coming soon.
So some dependencies are not
yet available to you.
When it is, we'll write a
tutorial on how to do that.
How to update a Notepad
applications and provide a
[INAUDIBLE] simple code
for you to work from.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Thanks Alain.
And with that, I will just
show you the link to our
documentation page which is
developers.google.com/drive.
It already talks about
writing Drive
application on Android, but--
as Alain said--
some pieces you need
are not there yet.
They will be available soon.
There are some pieces in the
Google Play services, but they
should be available soon.
And you also have
our contacts.
So our email addresses, are
Google+ accounts, and my
Twitter account.
And if you have any questions,
this is the time to ask them.
And if you do, please use the
microphones there and there.
As an incentive, we might have
some shwag which might be
either a t-shirt or a
self driving car.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
You never know.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: We
haven't decided yet.
But if you want to know?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You pick.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Ask questions.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Question.
You were
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: First.
AUDIENCE: So now we can
also save some work
offline with Drive?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So this
application which we developed
works offline, because every
time we do something in our
application it saves to
a local database.
And then it syncs.
That's one of the advantages
of using a Sync Adapter.
And as the Sync Adapter takes
care of all the syncing.
So you only need to know how to
write to a local database.
And then as soon as you have
wi-fi, as soon as you have
connectivity, and if the Sync
Adapter is enabled, then
syncing will be done.
That's why we implemented this
Sync Adapter pattern.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
guidelines for Sync Adapter?
Because let's say if I have two
devices, I'm modifying the
same file on two different
devices and they are offline.
One line is changed differently
on one device.
Same line is changed differently
on other device.
What are the recommendation
to handle this?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So of course
the first device to be
connected will push
its changes first.
And then the second one will try
to push its changes first.
And it's up to the sync logic
implementing our application
to merge them.
And our application
is pretty simple.
We don't really do
line by line data
merge or anything fancy.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I think we're
doing last [INAUDIBLE].
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, so we
basically lose the first
change if there are two
concurrent changes.
But this is a limitation
in our application.
It's up to the developers to
implement a sync logic that
takes care of that.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
He was next.
AUDIENCE: So if I understand
correctly, this is replacing
[INAUDIBLE]?
Or is there a way to integrate
that so we don't need to set a
time in the refresh settings.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So, I don't
know if you went to the Drive
talk this morning from
[INAUDIBLE].
We are working on adding push
notifications to the API.
So this would go, probably,
through [INAUDIBLE].
I don't have details on
implementation yet.
It's going to be available.
Right now it's not.
So the application has to
pull data from Drive.
And the best way to do it is
using the changes feed,
because you don't get the
entire users directory.
You only get files that has
changed since the last sync.
AUDIENCE: One more question.
You said everything right now
is not available yet.
But do you know if it is going
to be added to the Android
support library so we can use
it in all their devices?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: That's
a good idea.
We're going to talk with the
Android team, and we'll make
it available on the Android SDK
or make it available in a
separate repository.
But it's going to be public
and open source.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: The plan is
not to only add it to the last
version, jelly bean, but
also previous ones.
We don't have details yet,
but that's what they're
working on right now.
So seeing how this can go down
to other versions of that.
Basically all devices
can have it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Looking at your
example code, you were showing
the account user every time.
Would you recommend developers
steering clear of retrying the
last account selected?
Is there a specific reason why
you try and stay clear of
retrying that, looking for an
error, and then presenting the
account chooser?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: In our
sample app, we store the
chosen account in
the preferences.
So we simply store the name of
the account, because we're
going to need that to
get an access token.
If we have that, and the user is
trying to change accounts,
we prompt the dialogue.
And tell the intent that the
user previously chose this
account so please
preselect it.
In the case so of when we're
opening a file from Drive, we
don't know who opened
the file.
So we could use a preferred
account.
We didn't do that, but that's
a good way to [INAUDIBLE]
an account.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That's
actually no guarantee that the
last user selected in our
application is the same user
that is opening a file from
the Drive application.
AUDIENCE: But would there be
any difference between
separate users who both
have read access to a
file opening the file?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Well you
don't know if the other user
has read access.
AUDIENCE: But you'd get an error
message back, at which
point you could present
the account selector.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Another
approach could be to try and
see if they use it again.
But then if the user can't, you
don't know if it's because
it's a wrong user or if because
there is some other
problem, let's say.
So I would say that right now,
the recommended approach is to
show the dialogue every
time when it starts
from the Drive up.
But, as Alain said, we know it
is probably not the best user
experience.
So we might change this.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so if you want
to use Google Drive to hold
say a text file for, like you
said before, a game save or a
settings replication or
something, is there any way
that you can prevent the user
from using anything but your
application to access
that file?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Sorry can
you repeat the last part of
the question?
Prevent the user from?
AUDIENCE: Accessing it through
Drive, or whatever else, and
modifying it.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: [INAUDIBLE]
tags, [INAUDIBLE], in the
files metadata that you can
set and one is hidden.
So you can set a file is hidden,
so it won't show on
the Drive UI, but will still be
accessible through the API
for your application.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: In that case,
let's say, a smart user
will be still able to
access it, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: If a user
searched for it in the Drive
UI, it will appear in
the search results.
But it won't appear
by default.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So the thing
to remember here is that
Drive is a user managed
storage.
So the user has final decision
over it's files.
You cannot just create a file
and prevent him from, let's
say, deleting or tampering
with it.
So if that is a problem, then
Drive is probably not the
right solution.
It's up to your app, but
I would say that
just remember that.
There's no real way
to prevent that.
The user can always, always,
override your settings.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned there
was a dependency on the Google
Play Accounts Manager, what
was it called, the SO?
Is there a time frame for when
this will be available?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
It's coming soon.
Even us don't have
all the details,
because it's from Android.
But it's coming soon.
If you went to the talk
yesterday on what's new in the
Android SDK, or if you
watch it again, they
will talk about it.
And also, if you go
to the session,
we mentioned writing--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Right after this.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes,
Building Android Apps
[INAUDIBLE]
Web APIs from your
[INAUDIBLE].
He will also mention
those new APIs from
the Google Play services.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So actually
the section we're mentioning
is specifically about this
authorization part which is
part of this new Google
Play services.
AUDIENCE: OK, as a second part
to this, during the demo you
showed that whenever the user
needed to give authorization
in the very beginning there
was a little notification
thing at the top.
Is there any way to make
it come forward to the
foreground?
Because I think most users won't
notice this, because
even during the demo
you got other
notifications at the top.
I didn't know if this was
related to the app or not.
How are you going to
let the user know?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So
I decided to use the
notification system
because it's less
invasive to the user.
But it's coming from a
background Sync Adapter, and
you can also decide to start
a new activity instead of
pushing a notification
to the user.
So this is up to your
application.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Any other
questions anyone?
No?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So with that,
thank you very much.